morning there's promising news in the
fight against diabetes about 2 million
Americans have type 1 diabetes and the
number of cases is rising the FDA
recently approved a drug to delay the
onset of symptoms for people at high
risk of developing type 1 diabetes our
chief medical correspondent Dr John
lapuke shows how the treatment could buy
years of Health without the need for
insulin replacement
from an early age Anna Ferguson saw how
type 1 diabetes affected her older
sister Kate her mood and her feelings it
would change with her glucose levels but
I also knew that I would never want to
experience what she was going through in
type 1 diabetes the immune system
mistakenly destroys insulin-producing
cells in the pancreas when Ferguson was
five blood tests showed she had certain
antibodies that meant her risk of
developing diabetes over the next five
years was about 75 percent her mother
Meg could only wait and hope as she hit
that age 12 and her blood sugar started
to go out of whack
and it was kind of all right now what
are we going to do that's when
Ferguson's parents enrolled her in a
clinical trial led by Yale University
immunologist Dr Kevin Harold it's an
intravenous infusion of a specially
designed monoclonal antibody called
teasield instead of half of the people
developing diabetes in two years half of
the people developed diabetes in four
years it probably changes the ability of
cells that are responsible for killing
the insulin-producing cells when you saw
those results what was your reaction to
be perfectly honest I was hoping it
would be even longer but anytime without
diabetes is a gift Dr Harold says a
breakthrough in diabetes treatment is
long overdue we have better insulins we
have methods of delivering it that have
advanced significantly but it's never as
perfect as your own pancreas in making
insulin could this same approach be used
for other autoimmune diseases now our
approach is when someone presents with
rheumatoid arthritis or psoriasis or
type 1 diabetes or Ms we treat them
after they have disease it certainly
would be a lot better to prevent it from
happening while she was earning her
degree at the University of Maine Anna
Ferguson's blood sugar became too high
again so she traveled to New Haven for a
second round of teasield infusions we
are side effects have been relatively
mild in the second round of treatment
the now 21 year old had flu-like
symptoms how long is the infusion over
what period 30 minutes even if it
doesn't buy her more time without
insulin the family is grateful for the
gift she's already received what's it
meant to both of you to have these last
nine years doing really well without any
need for injections or anything it was
great to be able to get through all that
you know focus on being a teenager and
having fun I feel incredibly lucky and
you know holding out hope that it works
but you never know with science you
never know right the future is
wonderfully blank and if it could
continue to be like that without any
obstacles I think that'd be great
the list price of a single course of
therapy is a hundred and ninety three
thousand dollars but consider this
people with diabetes spend an average of
nearly ten thousand dollars a year on
related medical expenses although a
one-time treatment is expensive t-zeeled
could be a cost-saving treatment over
the lifetime of young people like Anna
we'll see I mean insulin's coming down
for some people so at least there's that
um look this is medicine for type 1
diabetes correct could it potentially
work for people with type 2 diabetes
and remind us what's the difference
between the two right it's only type one
okay type 1 diabetes is an autoimmune
disease where for some reason your
immune system gets screwed up and it
starts attacking your own pancreas and
that's where the cells are that make
insulin type 2 diabetes there actually
is insulin around although the the
amount of insulin can go down a little
bit but the problem there is insulin
resistance your cells are not responding
to it adequately so no this is for an
autoimmune disease like Diabetes Type 1.
Dr Le poop this sounds like a game
changer what could this do for other
autoimmune diseases yeah this is what is
so compelling and is really pumping me
up and I want to get ahead of myself so
okay just cautious very excited I am
excited about it because think about it
we treat we we try to prevent other
other problems right heart disease we
lower cholesterol we treat high blood
pressure so that people don't develop
the problems okay but with autoimmune
disease and it's not just diabetes you
know it's it's lupus it's multiple
sclerosis rheumatoid arthritis can go on
and on and on we wait until so the
actual symptoms come and they're in
full-bone disease imagine if there's a
window of opportunity before that where
you could somehow identify that this
immune system is about to go haywire and
it's smoldering it's going to like just
like Embers and you can throw a glass of
water on it and it goes just calm it
down we understand your excitement
thanks so much Dr Le puke